the Democratic National Committee is not
going to allow Fox News to moderate a
debate in the Democratic primary for the
2020 presidential nomination and the
reasons why basically are focused on the
ties between the Trump administration
and the Republican Party and Fox News
Fox News has sort of unofficially been
the propaganda arm of the Republican
Party for a really long time but earlier
this week we had this amazing piece from
Jane Mayer and her investigation which
exposed more of the full extent of the
connections between the Trump
administration and Fox News Channel for
example we now know that Fox News had
the stormy Daniels Donald Trump a legal
hush money payments story before Donald
Trump's election and they chose to kill
that story allegedly for political
reasons we know about the crossover
between Fox News personalities and
contributors and Donald Trump staffers
we know about the restrictions placed on
Fox news anchors about what they're
allowed to say about Donald Trump and
Fox put out a statement that's pretty
clever
by throwing Chris Wallace's name into it
saying why won't Chris Wallace be
allowed Chris Wallace is someone who
should be allowed to ask people
questions and it would be valuable he's
one of two people who sometimes make
sense on the channel and I'll talk about
the meaning of that Fox News senior vice
president and managing editor bill
Sammon responded to this decision by the
DNC saying quote we hope the DNC will
reconsider its decision to bar chris
wallace brett bayer and martha maccallum
all of whom embody the ultimate
journalistic integrity and
professionalism from moderating a
Democratic presidential debate they're
the best debate team in the business and
they offer can that it's an important
opportunity to make the case to make
their case to the largest TV news
audience in America which includes many
persuadable voters this is straight out
of Noam Chomsky and Edward Herman's
propaganda model okay let me just
refresh your memory I've said before
Shep Smith and Chris Wallace sometimes
say logical things
on Fox News when the president obviously
lies they pointed out for example and
before I've hypothesized dis FoxNews
allow this as a form of sort of
controlled opposition so that they can
justify that they are actually a news
station with diverse points of view who
hold the administration accountable and
here they are saying that's a bad
decision because Chris Wallace isn't
going to be allowed and what the Chomsky
Herman propaganda model specifically
predicts this is a book from 1988 by the
way the original edition I'm rereading
it now the propaganda model predicts
that you would see some degree of
disagreement and dissent allowed within
corporate media outlets even if it is a
departure from their overall editorial
perspective specifically as a pretext to
be able to claim that their objective
and that there's a diversity of opinions
but it's really very calibrated
opposition and dissent so I'll give you
an example Shep Smith is allowed on Fox
News to point out when the president has
told an obvious lie but you don't have
anyone on Fox News that questions the
systems of power that allowed such media
consolidation to take place and have
allowed the relationships that now exist
between government and media to grow to
the degree that they have you just get
Chris Wallace who doesn't let John
Bolton get away with an obvious lie for
example or Shep Smith that points out
there is no actual crisis at the border
and then Fox News is able to say why
would you bar someone like Chris Wallace
who's so good an objective and fair from
moderating a democratic debate exactly
what the propaganda model would predict
and I also want to mention there's a lot
of myths reporting about what this story
is about there are some reports that are
saying Fox is banned from broadcasting
debates that's not really what's at
issue here the primary debates are often
on one network they are not like the
general election debates although we're
really to depend
on how they're structured what we're
talking about here is foxnews getting a
debate to moderate in the Democratic
primary um and I think that this
actually makes a lot of sense I think
it's a waste of time for Democrats to
try to connect with the Fox News
audience specifically if you are a voter
and you're seriously considering voting
in the Democratic primary and you're
trying to get information about the
candidates
you're not going to suffer a significant
disadvantage because you can't go to Fox
News for a Democratic primary and one
criticism I've read is the reason the
DNC is doing this is because they don't
want to take tough questions from Fox
News debate moderators that doesn't make
any sense it's all Democrats right it's
not like Fox News is going to bring on a
Democrat and a Republican and give
tougher questions or stricter treatment
to the Democrat we're talking about
Democratic primary debates the questions
in total could either hurt or help
candidates sort of equally but the idea
of targeting in that way I don't think
is actually the concern but consider
what it is the DNC is supposed to be
doing the DNC is not supposed to be
helping one particular candidate over
others in the way that many allege that
they did with Hillary Clinton over
Bernie Sanders in 2016 the role of the
DNC is to help Democratic voters decide
who they want to run against Donald
Trump and to do everything they can to
defeat Donald Trump in 2020 how does a
debate on Fox News help them do that
Pat so I think that this is the right
decision I don't think that it is an
issue of censorship it's certainly not
an issue of free speech not every
network or channel is going to even get
a Democratic primary debate and it's the
decision I would have made if I was the
DNC well just to step back for a moment
is it possible that some of these
Democratic candidates could potentially
convince some members of the Fox News
audience if they frame the issues in the
right way
like if a Democratic candidate talks
about how it's unfair that some of the
most profitable corporations in the
world some of the richest people in the
world barely pay taxes or don't pay
taxes at all I could see
some fox news audience members
questioning that right maybe being
persuaded or if Democratic candidate
talks about how every other modern
developed country in the world has
universal health care views health care
as a right and the United States doesn't
maybe that could raise some eyebrows
from the conservative Fox News viewers
maybe you could change the minds I don't
know maybe there's a potential for this
to be good if if you reach out and and
put Democratic candidates in front of a
Fox News audience but this is a primary
this is a primary there's plenty of time
for them to do that when we get to the
actual general election debates if the
risk is Fox will do what they did to me
when I went on Fox they give everybody
this bad lighting they make the room so
hot that if the candidates are sweating
and they make them look uncomfortable
and not good I I think you're right and
that's why Fox should televise the
general election debates and then the
Democratic candidate can make their fate
their case in front of the Fox News
audience I think it's the right decision
when it comes to the primary debates not
everybody gets the broadcast rather to
moderate a primary debate Fox News is
just one of the places where there will
not be a Democratic primary debate and I
think that it's the absolute right
decision one of the day's sponsors is
privacy dot-com / Pakman which is a free
service that I myself use really useful
in many different ways takes just a few
seconds to link your debit card to
privacy calm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the Internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a david pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy comm icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically
entered I can put in any zip code I want
and I'm done and if you try to use my
credit card number that you just saw on
the screen it doesn't matter because
I've already deleted that virtual card
and that's the beauty of privacy calm
there are a ton of advantages to using a
free service like this for example you
can sign up for as many free trials as
you want then just delete the virtual
credit card you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time it is all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time they're giving everyone
in our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link